zugegeben die frage ob selbstfahrender
autos ihre besitzer einmal umbringen
sollen dürfen ist schon irgendwie total
verrückt aber es könnte situationen
geben in denen das einmal sinnvoll sein
könnte ein jahrzehnte altes
gedankenexperiment wird jetzt wieder
relevant
in den siebziger jahren wurde das erste
mal ein gedankenexperiment beschrieben
das bis heute noch gerne von philosophen
verwendet wird das experiment heißt dass
trolley probleme und funktioniert in
etwa so ein zug ist außer kontrolle
geraten und fährt unaufhaltsam auf fünf
personen zu die sich nicht rechtzeitig
weg bewegen können
du kannst allerdings durch das umstellen
einer weiche den zug auf ein anderes
gleis lenken
unglücklicherweise befindet sich auf
diesem gleis eine weitere person wie
entscheidest du dich stellst du die
weiche und tut es damit aktiv einen
menschen oder entscheidest du dich
nichts zu tun und damit fünf menschen
leben zu nehmen
obwohl viel davon hätten verschont
werden können viele würden instinktiv
argumentieren dass fünf menschenleben
mehr wert sind als eines und dass man
deswegen die weiche umstellen sollte man
versucht instinktiv den schaden
möglichst gering zu halten und je nach
betrachtungsweise gibt einen der
deutsche staat dafür sogar nicht einmal
die schuld man würde also nicht wegen
mordes in den knast wandern genaue
erklärung dazu unten in den fußnoten
unter dem video
ok und was hat das jetzt mit
selbstfahrenden autos zu tun
inzwischen vergeht eigentlich kaum noch
eine woche in der man nichts neues aus
der autonomen autos branche hört google
mercedes volvo vielleicht apple und
sogar das taxiunternehmen juba arbeiten
bereits alle an selbstfahrenden autos
die teilweise schon im öffentlichen
verkehr fahren dürfen und inzwischen
weiß eigentlich jeder dass google selbst
fahrende autos es war schon in mehrere
unfälle verwickelt waren
aber dass kein einziger dieser unfälle
die schuld von den google autos war
sondern immer die schuld von
menschlichen fahrern das unternehmen
verpasst selten eine chance dass immer
wieder zu unterstreichen
und es ist auch wirklich erwähnenswert
denn einer der gründe für den riesigen
hype um selbstfahrender autos ist ihre
größere sicherheit jedes jahr sterben in
den usa 33.000 menschen durch
verkehrsunfälle in deutschland sind es
etwa 3300 die allermeisten davon
entstehen immer durch menschliche fehler
schlafmangel unaufmerksamkeit aufs handy
gucken selbst fahrende autos lassen sich
nicht ablenken werden nicht müde und
können 360 grad um sich herum alles
sehen was passiert hunderte male in der
sekunde
aber egal wie gut und sicher
selbstfahrender autos sind früher oder
später wird sich eines in einer
situation wie dem trolley dilemma wieder
finden
fährt das auto geradeaus über das kleine
kind oder setzt es den wagen gegen die
wand über fährt man den backpacker am
straßenrand oder fährt das aus für die
klippe herunter
zugegeben das klingt jetzt alles nach
weit hergeholten situation aber wenn
erst mal jedes zweite auto auf der
straße ein computergesteuertes ist dann
wird jede situation passieren die auch
passieren kann
alleine in der kurzen test zeit der
google autos sind die ingenieure bereits
über die skurrilsten situationen
gestolpert die ich jemals gehört habe
in einer 30er zone musste das auto
anhalten weil eine alte dame im
rollstuhl mit ihrem besen eine ente
gejagt hat mitten auf der straße man
kann einfach nicht jede situation im
straßenverkehr vorprogrammiert geht
einfach nicht aber wie das trolley
dilemma zeigt manchmal kann es sinnvoll
sein ein leben zu opfern wenn man
dadurch viele menschenleben retten kann
und sollte man so etwas dann nicht in
die selbstfahrenden autos einbauen auch
wenn das bedeutet dass menschen sich
autos kaufen würden die dazu
programmiert sind sie in bestimmten
situationen umzubringen
ich finde diesen kompromiss sollte man
eingehen aber hier hört das dilemma noch
nicht auf einige jahre später wurde das
gedankenexperiment um das vettermann
problem ergänzt in dieser situation gibt
es nur noch ein gleis mit fünf menschen
und keine weiche mehr stattdessen stehst
du jetzt auf einer brücke über den
gleisen zusammen mit einem fetten man
wenn du den mann von der brücke auf die
gleise stößt würde das den zug aus
bremsen bevor er die fünf menschen
erreicht und hier haben die meisten
menschen direkt ein problem damit einen
menschen leben zu opfern um mehrere zu
retten
obwohl das experiment unterm strich das
gleiche ist ist es doch ganz anders
stellt euch vor ihr fahrt mit eurem
selbst fahrenden auto auf der autobahn
neben euch wird ein mann mit seinem jeep
mit voller geschwindigkeit auf einen
kinder schulbus zu und euer auto ist das
einzige das sich noch dazwischen
schmeißen könnte sollte es das tun
ich bin es fühlt sich irgendwie falsch
an weil die mit der situation überhaupt
nichts zu tun hat
aber unterm strich ist dieses
gedankenexperiment genau das gleiche wie
das floriade
instinktiv wollen die meisten menschen
den man nicht herunter stoßen und dass
sich das eigene auto als puffer zwischen
zwei andere stellt finden die meisten
auch eher befremdlich anscheinend
treffen wir hier irgendwo zwischen den
beiden szenarien auf eine grenze und
genau diese ethische grenze müssen wir
finden im film i robot geht es um ein
ganz ähnliches thema
hier wird unser protagonist von einem
roboter gerettet weil er die höhere
überlebenschancen hatte das kleine
mädchen musste sterben obwohl unser
protagonist versucht hatte dem roboter
zu signalisieren dass das mädchen zuerst
gerettet werden sollen
diese entscheidungen ein zu
programmieren das was für uns menschen
total natürlich ist ist nicht leicht
vielleicht sogar das größte problem der
robotik im moment fahren immer
mindestens zwei ingenieure in einem
selbst fahrenden auto mit die zu jedem
zeitpunkt eingreifen können und die
situation übernehmen können und das ist
auch ziemlich gut so denn obwohl die
meisten selbstfahrenden autos
technologisch schon recht
fortgeschritten sind und extrem viel
strecke zurückgelegt haben können sie
noch sehr viele simple dinge nicht tun
bei schnee und starkem regen sind die
autos zum beispiel immer noch nicht
sicher weil die sensoren nicht
funktionieren straßenlöcher werden oft
überhaupt nicht erkannt und einfach
überfahren und googles autos und extrem
abhängig von googles kartenservice
ampeln die nicht im system sind werden
einfach nicht erkannt
zumindest ein großes problem der
selbstfahrenden autos wurde vor wenigen
tagen endlich gelöst und zwar die
rechtliche frage wer bei einem auto
unfall verantwortlich ist autohersteller
volvo geht einen schritt voraus und
übernimmt in zukunft die verantwortung
für alle unfälle die ihre autos
verursachen werden
und das ist auch irgendwie sinnvoll denn
der fahrer der das auto gekauft hat
macht ja nichts
er macht keine fehler jetzt bleibt
eigentlich nur abzuwarten wie die
anderen hersteller darauf reagieren
werden
ob wir in 15 oder 20 jahren endlich die
ersten selbstfahrenden autos kaufen
können weiß heute ja eigentlich noch
keiner
aber moment herrscht eine sehr
interessante diskussion unter eltern
über diesen technologischen fortschritt
sollte mein kind überhaupt noch einen
führerschein machen
ein sohn eines google ingenieurs ist
jetzt elf jahre alt das gesetzte ziel
des unternehmens ist es dass er niemals
einen führerschein machen muss in
amerika ist das mit 16 jahren also will
google 2020 die ersten selbstfahrenden
autos auf der straße haben über setzt
sich übrigens genau das gleiche ziel
aber ist das wirklich fair für das kind
die einen sagen das autofahren eine
wichtige fähigkeit ist die man
beherrschen sollte und die zum
erwachsenwerden dazu gehört andere
wiederum sagen dass die meisten
heutzutage auch keine pferde mehr reiten
können oder ihre eigenen kartoffeln
anbauen können was früher
überlebenswichtig war es heute ein hobby
geworden
wir entwickeln uns eben weiter und bei
diesem prozess gehen auch traditionen
und fähigkeiten verloren
was meint ihr dazu sollte euer selbst
fahren das auto dazu programmiert werden
euch in bestimmten fällen umzubringen um
andere zu retten und werden kinder bald
schon keinen führerschein mehr machen
schreibt mir eure gedanken und meinungen
dazu unten in die kommentare ich bin
schon mega gespannt was ihr zu diesem
spannenden und vor allem ziemlich
relevanten thema zu sagen habt hier
rechts findet ihr meine letzten videos
wenn ihr mich noch nicht auf twitter und
facebook verfolgt dann solltet ihr das
hier unten nachholen irgendwo da genau
und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch ein
schönes wochenende bis nächste woche